me gustaría comenzar con algo que todos
nosotros tenemos en común
nosotros todos compartimos una red
estamos conectados
intercomunicados de alguna manera pero
da lo mismo
de cualquier manera si yo digo la red no
estoy diciendo una emisora radial estoy
hablando de las redes sociales todos
sabemos que es una red social
todos tenemos pertenecemos estamos en
una red social algunas son más conocidas
que otras pero no importa más allá de
cuál sea esta red que cada uno usamos lo
importante es saber que todos estamos en
una red y con la red es decir todos
nosotros estamos en red conectados
intercomunicados pero además estamos con
la red como sucede con el mundo porque
nosotros todos para diferenciarlos
diferenciarlos de otros seres vivimos en
red
vivimos relacionados intercomunicados
en el mundo y con el mundo
ahora está buenísimo que eso suceda no
vamos a negar la importancia que tienen
las redes sociales hoy en día son
recontra importantes para los laburos
para un montón de otras cosas son súper
importantes y está buenísimo que suceda
que todos nosotros todos nosotros
podamos imaginarnos que estamos
conectados intercomunicados con luz con
nudos perdón repito para las cámaras con
nudos con lazos inter con tener
interconectados todos nosotros está
buenísimo imaginar lo que realmente es
así pero alguna vez se pusieron a pensar
cómo es esta red imaginaria que nos
contiene a todos cómo son esas redes
son como las redes deportivas por
ejemplo somos como la red de un partido
de tenis que vemos pasar la pelotita
diez o doce veces por partido hasta que
por ahí
cazamos una
o no casamos ni una
o somos eso sería por ejemplo como ver
pasar la vida de un lado para el otro y
no involucrarnos nunca
o somos como una red de un partido de
fútbol
cuadrados
con la hinchada atrás alentando o
puteando
expectante de lo que sucede en el
partido esperando que por favor no nos
toque un 0 a 0 porque no nos mueve en la
zona de la fibra de la que estamos
hechos
es decir estamos todo el tiempo pensando
qué es lo que nos dicen desde atrás que
deberíamos hacer o no hacer esperando
que alguna emoción nos sacuda un poco
o somos como las redes de los aros de
básquet bien abiertos por arriba y por
abajo bien entrelazados la pelota la
emoción nos sacude 1 2 3 4 70 veces por
partido
se vuelve tan repetitiva la emoción que
pierde sentido
pero igual nosotros estamos esperando
expectante de que alguna bola alguna
pelota nos llene de emoción o será en
realidad
que somos como una red de pesca
encerrados en nosotros mismos
apretujados todos los peces tratando de
no salir del agua al canto de nada
haremos nada haremos como en buscando a
nemo
o será que nada haremos
más allá de como cada uno de ustedes y
nosotros nos imaginemos cómo es esta red
lo importante es saber que nosotros
estamos en la red y con la red como
sucede con el mundo nosotros estamos en
el mundo y con el mundo relacionándonos
pero qué pasaría si en vez de estar con
las redes virtuales nosotros
estuviésemos en la red todo el tiempo
es una pregunta que le voy a dejar para
dentro un rato
me gustaría ahora tratar de desarrollar
una teoría que tengo conocen ustedes el
mito de narciso
y el lago
bien para los gracias para los que no lo
conocen el mito de narciso cuenta que
narciso era joven
un joven perdón por la dicción un joven
muy muy hermoso
que al verse reflejado en la imagen de
un lago cristalino despejado se enamoró
de su imagen y se enamoró tanto que no
podía dejar de buscarse se sentía tan
atraído por esa imagen que le reflejaba
que no paraba de querer retrasarse y no
se podía alcanzar porque al momento de
que quería tocarse su imagen se
desvanecía y así en ese vaivén de querer
alcanzarse de querer asirse pero nunca
encontrarse se volvió loco y se murió
es un mito ponerle algunos dice que en
realidad se ahogó en el lago
vale decir se ahogó en su propia imagen
no importa
porque lo que me importa de ese mito no
es narciso perdón narciso
por herir tu herida narcisista están
abiertas tanto ya
lo que me interesa de ese mito es el
espejo es el lago
el reflejo cristalino la imagen que nos
seduce lo que nos enamora los que nos
atrae los que nos incita a verlo hasta
dejar de vernos a nosotros mismos porque
ese espejo a través de los años nosotros
lo fuimos achicando el espejo no
desapareció lo fuimos achicando pero a
medida que eso sucedió lo que fue
creciendo con el tiempo fue nuestra
necesidad y nuestras ansias de
alcanzarlo
lo voy a explicar un poco más
detalladamente con algunos hechos como
para que lo podamos incorporar mejor
materializarlo para decirlo de alguna
otra manera
lo primero que hicimos fue sacar ese
espejo del lago es el lago de su entorno
natural sacarlo y ponerlo al pie de una
montaña le recortamos los márgenes lo
inclinamos un poco quizás para no tener
que agachar nos por las lumbares y lo
llamamos escena es que en el teatro no
lo hicimos nosotros lo hicieron los
griegos hace 2500 años si todos nosotros
fuéramos griegos de hace 2.500 años
iríamos al pie de la montaña a ver es el
agua ese espejo ese reflejo que nos
enamora que nos seduce que nos cuenta
las historias
estaba buenísimo cuando eso sucedía pero
no nos alcanzó entonces lo seguimos
achicando y los sacamos del pie de la
montaña donde estaba y lo pusimos en el
medio de la ciudad los cercanos y le
llamamos circo romano
ahí seguíamos contando las historias que
hubiésemos querido repetir nuestras
hazañas los héroes los que nos enamoran
en el circo romano pero no nos alcanzó y
lo volvimos a achicar y lo sacamos del
circo romano y lo pusimos un tiempo en
las iglesias después de la iglesia
también nos aburrimos lo pusimos en el
teatro isabelino y también nos aburrimos
para ser vago en el relato porque
pasaron muchas otras cosas más y los
pusimos en un teatro como el que
conocemos todos como todos pueden haber
ido alguna vez o saben que existe que es
el teatro colon el teatro el círculo en
la ciudad rosario por ejemplo que son
los teatros los edificios teatrales como
los conocemos hace 300 años
aproximadamente ahora
en el siglo 20 ese espejo ese reflejo
eso que nos enamora
no masificados y de qué manera dejar los
sacamos del escenario y lo proyectamos
en una pantalla
lo más eficaz a través del cine
proyectamos nuestros deseos ahí
y dijimos bueno acá ya está por fin
tenemos el espejo ahí lo estamos viendo
es materializado ya lo tenemos no nos
alcanzó
no nos alcanzó y que hicimos hicimos un
recorrido vertiginoso y pasamos del cine
a la televisión de la televisión a las
computadoras de las computadoras a las
notebook de las notebook a las tablets
de las tablets al reloj
y ahora parece que sí que lo tenemos al
alcance de la mano acá el espejo lo
deseado lo imaginado la imagen
proyectada
capaz porque así lo podemos agarrar más
fácil
pero la teoría no es solamente que el
espejo los fuimos achicando sino a que a
medida que esto pasó en nuestras ansias
de ser protagonista de las historias de
vivenciar esas historias narradas de ser
los héroes
desde el quijote para atrás y para
adelante todos alguna vez soñamos por lo
menos una vez con ser protagonistas de
esas historias con ser los héroes o las
heroínas de esas historias esas
historias que nos enamoran que nos
permiten ser lo que quisiéramos ser pero
no podemos
también lo que nos ilusiona lo que nos
incita a ir para adelante
esas ansias de protagonismo fueron
creciendo tanto no solamente por
nosotros sino también un poco por
egoísmo un poco por narcisismo un poco
también por otras cosas que no tienen
que ver con nosotros sino con la
sociedad de consumo y creció tanto esa
imagen y ese deseo y esa ansia de ser
protagonista y nuestra propia imagen
proyectada que ya no caben en las
pantallas tan chiquitas que fuimos
achicando a través de los años
esas ansias ese deseo de imagen
proyectada
eso que proyectamos encontró un lugar
ideal
en las redes sociales
un lugar donde cada uno de nosotros
podemos elegir nuestro nombre si no nos
gusta el que nos pusieron
podemos aplaudir dar fuerza
mandar cositas de guiño para arriba
aplaudir mandar besos te entrego el
corazón lloró río
todo en 15 minutos
a través de emoticones que son emociones
y con izadas
emoticones
hagamos un breve ejercicio en 10 o 15
minutos repasemos no 10-15 minutos si no
nosotros mentalmente ahora acá repasemos
no todo un día de charlas sino como son
10 o 15 minutos de chateo en una red
social nosotros saludamos besamos amamos
reímos lloramos odiamos
volvemos a reír volvemos a llorar
mandamos besos lloramos de nuevo
mandamos el corazón todo
en 15 minutos
qué pasaría
si en lugar de ser la imagen proyectada
de narciso en el espejo
pasamos pasaremos a hacer narciso
en cuerpo presente
y quisiésemos vivir todas estas
emociones no soportaríamos en 15 minutos
porque las emociones
necesitan un espacio y un tiempo para
desarrollarse en nuestro cuerpo
pero no es tan fácil
no es tan fácil llegar a esa emoción
no es tan fácil que nosotros nos
permitamos emocionarnos no es fácil
siquiera que la sociedad permita que
nosotros nos podamos vincular con
nuestra emoción con nuestro cuerpo
y mucho menos cuando tenemos la idea de
que ese cuerpo es solamente una caja de
tránsito hacia otro lugar que no sabemos
si existe si no existe o qué
pero las cosas se vivencian en vigo
aunque suene redundante las emociones se
sienten
no se sienten se sienten
los besos se dan en vivo
las caricias se sienten en la piel
los abrazos se aprietan contra el pecho
las lágrimas se derraman por alguna
causa
no está bueno amar gratuitamente ni
odiar sin ninguna causa
no está bueno reír sin ningún motivo
y mucho menos está bueno tener una risa
falsa ja ja ja
porque cuando eso sucede
nosotros nos transformamos en pésimos
actores de nuestra vida pero no ya en
las redes sociales
si no en la vida real
a través de los años en estos últimos
años las amistades virtuales se
multiplicaron
pero sentir un compañero un amigo un
abrazo alguien que te contenga no sufrió
la misma multiplicación
en la vida real
si decir te amo
cuesta lo mismo que lo que le cuesta a
un celular poner dos palabritas seguidas
entonces hay algo que estamos haciendo
mal o en algo estamos fallando
yo no creo que debamos
anular
las redes sociales
porque lo que somos somos seres sociales
necesitamos estar comunicados
necesitamos estar en relación
no lo vamos a poder cambiar porque eso
es lo que somos es parte de lo que somos
y de lo que tenemos en común
entonces sigamos amando odiando puteando
besando
sufriendo
lo que cada uno quiera
pero si lo primero que vamos a hacer es
ponerlo en instagram
por lo menos cuatro o cinco veces antes
ensayemos los
entre nosotros en la vida real